the boat cruise along a water channel
that opens up to Lakes Albert and Edward
is
breathtaking you can see animals on the
shores of Queen Elizabeth National Park
the busiest in
Uganda this is the highlight of tourists
visiting here the number of elephants
buffaloes and hippos has increased in
the last several decades that is
reversing years of decline caused by
poers and encroach M on Wildlife areas
all this will be here there are many you
see officials attribute this to uganda's
protection efforts but there is another
challenge climate change as well as a
new invasive weed that is killing
healthy plants because climate
change the speed at which it's
moving I don't think whether we catch up
with speed because you try to manipulate
one plant here another plant comes up
you when we were moving when you saw
those big elephants that is the area we
tried to remove the dtis area and
immediately after the D SC area the
panium came
in ugandans who live near the park also
say they're leaving a nightmare a big
problem here is human Wildlife conflicts
elephants are increasingly going into
villages in search of pure and
water Austin kabagambe shows us where a
hard of elephants destroyed his crops
they come here nearly every day he says
the park has been partially fenced but
this side is still
open we try to chase the animals using
many means for example fire and vuelas
we often sleep at the farm to protect
our yield a neighbor was killed by
elephants on the other side of the
village other Farmers say hippos have
invaded their rice farms and killed
several people game Waters say they are
aware of the distress caused and try to
compensate those who have been affected
but they also blame those who block the
animals migration routes Katherine soy
Al jazer Queen Elizabeth National Park
Uganda make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer